you
BAM what's up you bad [ __ ]
yong-chol Joey here and for
[ __ ] effect you guys are saying
joy without how you've been I've been
busy [ __ ] I've been traveling with
the family for Easter but don't don't
don't know never [ __ ] count uncle
Joey ow
you don't meet though I got my reefer
with me oh [ __ ] this is death right here
you know me never [ __ ] around
I also brought my favorites now you go
[ __ ] 600 milligrams of debt tonight
you know I'm saying I haven't seen you
in a couple days
I figured I'd check in we get together
we smoke a little [ __ ] thing we talk
about Cruz and Trump [ __ ] Cruz's wife
in the muffler you know all [ __ ] like
that we got to talk about that's it [ __ ]
it's good friday [ __ ] Jews and
jumping up and down is the best day the
[ __ ] here for a Jew
I ain't got no a will for Jews I love
those [ __ ] [ __ ] white [ __ ]
around you know me well here we go
piece of [ __ ] heaven 400 no ain't
[ __ ] around no more I don't give a
[ __ ] if they killed Jesus enough you
know me I'm still eat my 600 800
milligram I got some sensational reform
got a couple vapor punch I'm gonna open
that I just wanna touch basically you
guys just a measure buddies all right
you know I still love you [ __ ]
I got your back
I'm just with the family this week I'm
making it happen I got the baby got the
[ __ ] what you w K&Z the Dutch station
and that's it the devil with smoke some
like 52 [ __ ] numbers tonight and
that's it relaxed I'm gonna relax
tomorrow I'm back home Sunday and I'll
see you [ __ ] Monday night for
the podcast next weekend Brea California
the [ __ ] improv we ain't playin
next weekend Jack I got peeps coming
through that Tommy Easter coming through
Thursday night I got my man [ __ ]
Johnny Rock from the leave side podcast
I got my man Jack I so do flea on we are
[ __ ] millions are coming they are made
to come in what the [ __ ] you better do
it yourself anyway that's it I'm gonna
sit around wait for the edibles to hit
me you've got a nice piece of fish
that's it my face [ __ ] completely I'm
just checking on you [ __ ] to
let you know I love you I didn't forget
about you
and have a great weekend be safe keep
your eyes open they kill the second in
command
Isis is gonna be [ __ ] everywhere this
weekend bring their bayonet when you
stabbed while he's [ __ ] in the
eyeball and [ __ ] they'll [ __ ] around on
we scan it not that [ __ ] remember
fear [ __ ] I'm scared every day but
I'm not scared it was [ __ ] I'm saying
[ __ ] it we [ __ ] in the museum we're
gonna die eventually [ __ ] shoot you
don't give a [ __ ] you spit their face
and tell them Viva America [ __ ]
and that's it I love you [ __ ]
are all my heart have a great week I
stay safe keep the eyes open and the
most important thing stay black
understand because they can't stop if
you stay black I love you [ __ ]
we're all my heart